السودان ماذا رصدتم حتى اللح
ظه نعم تجدد الاشتباكات كان هو الاعنف منذ
ان اندلعت هذه الحرب بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم سريع هذه الاشتباكات كانت
بالاسلحه الثقيله والرشاشات وكذلك
الطيران في بعض المناطق هذه
الاشتباكات تركزت في اتجاه الخرطوم بحري
وفي جنوب الخرطوم وفي شرق النيل كانت بشكل
مكثف على الرغم من ان الان حده هذه
الاشتباكات قلت ولكنها لم تتوقف الان نحن
نسمع ذوي الانفجارات في مناطق عده وتستمر
هذه الاشتباكات لربما يكون هنالك مزيد من
المواجهات في هذا المكان ايضا هنالك احد
كبير بالنسبه للمواطنين الذين يقومون
بالذهاب بحاوله يعني الحصول على
الضروريه وتحركاتهم فقط داخل الاحياء لا
يستطيعون الذهاب الى الطرق الرئيسيه حيث
توجد الاشتباكات بالاضافه لانه هنالك
مناشنات متكرره من
اللجنه الطبيه ومن الاطباء والقادر الصحيه
ووزاره الصحه في محاوله لتثبيت ما تم
الاتفاق عليه فيما يختص بفتح المسارات
الامنه ولكن يريدون صعوبه خاصه ان اللجنه
المركزيه للاطباء قد اصدر التقديرات لعدد
كبير من القتل الاسود وان كان هنا في
الخرطوم او في بعض الولايات وتقول ان
هنالك ايضا كبير من الجرحى يعانون في
الوصول الى المستشفيات ويعانون كذلك
الطبيه الوصول الى مستشفيات الطوارئ
لمحاوله انقاذ المصابين في مثل هذه الظروف
كذلك لا تزال الاوضاع ماساويه بالنسبه
للمستشفيات القريبه من مناطق الاشتباك في
بالقرب من القياده العامه والقصر الرئاسي
المعلومات ايضا تتحدث عن الاشتباكات اداره
في في بحر هذا الصباح اكثر
الهويه انفجار يكون هناك وكانت الاسلحه
الثقيله هي سيده الموقف في معركه اليوم
ايضا هنالك مناشدات من القوه السياسيه
مختلفه الكتله الديمقراطيه المجلس المركزي
الاحزاب السياسيه بمختلف مسمياتها وكذلك
المنظمات المجتمع المدني كلها اصدرت
بيانات تطالب على الاقل بوقف اطلاق النار
او عدد الاقل احترام الهدنه التي اعلنت
التي تبدا الساعه الثالثه بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه اليوم وحتى الساعه السادسه
باحترام هذه الهدنه حتى تستطيع ان تقوم
الجرحى او التوصيل المعينات والمساعدات
الانسانيه الضروريه كذلك ان نلاحظ انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي من معظم المدينه العاصمه
الخرطوم وانقطاع التيار الكهربائي هذا له
تبعات كبيره انسانيه يرتبط بتدفق المياه
الى المنازل بالنسبه للاحياء هنالك احياء
كثيره انقطعت عنها المياه وانقطعت عنها
الكهرباء ويواجهون صعوبات
كبيره وحيئه المياه المدن في الخرطوم دخول
انها تواجه ايضا صعوبات في الوصول الى
المحطات المياه التي كان بها اعطال حتى
الذين لهم علاقه بالكهرباء يقولون انهم
يواجهون صعوبات في الوصول لاصلاح اي عطل
سواء كان يتعلق بالكهرباء او يتعلق
بالمياه ايضا
هنالك محاولات ايضا
لاعاده التيار الكهربائي لكنه حتى الان
ليست هنالك ليس هنالك جديد في هذا الاطار
وهنالك
من المواطنين بان الاوضاع التي تدخل يومها
تتفاقم فيها الاوضاع الانسانيه بشكل عام
وهذا يحذر منه كثير من الذين يعتبرون ان
من استمرار هذا القتال يبدا واحده من اكبر
المسار التي يعاني منها السودان الانذار
تتجه الان
للجهود الافريقيه والعربيه والدوليه في
قناع الطرفين لوقت هذا القتال او اعلان هن
على الاقل حتى يستطيع المواطنه يقوم
بترتيبات اموره الحياتيه الخاصه نحن في
شهر رمضان هنالك الكثير من الاحتياجات
بهذا الوزاره على كل هذه هي الاجواء اجواء
مشحونه بالتوتر حتى المناطق الذي يحصل
فيها يحدث فيها هدوء لا يستطيع ان يستفيد
من الهدوء اي شخص لان الاشتباكات تتجدد
بشكل مفاجئ في اي اماكن وخاصه الطرق
الرئيسيه شكرا